One of my favorite ways to build EDH
decks is to chase a particular vibe,
a feeling that I want to infuse as much of as
possible into the DNA of a deck. A big instance
of this was chasing the feeling of raw power and
inevitability granted by big-lands decks, ramping
myself into being the untouchable god-king of a
particular EDH game. However, equally alluring
has been the exact opposite type of deck—a deck
that can cultivate the sort of low-to-the-ground,
cutthroat games that often characterize other
formats but are frequently absent in EDH. On my
end of things it’s absolutely possible to play
that kind of Magic—I can play a combat-focused
deck full of scrappy 2 and 3 drops, but the issue
is that this frequently doesn’t play well with the
sorts of decks that dominate most of the format.
Life totals are too high, ramp is too plentiful,
decks are designed to get too many resources
for a scrappy little pile of dudes to keep up.
Aggro can work, but most often it involves either
Voltron-esque methods or a strong commander such
as Torbran, Jetmir, or Anim Pakal to serve as a
core that binds together an otherwise disjointed
gameplan. That would be fine, but it wouldn’t
quite be the sort of cage fight Magic vision
I was going for—it would be me racing a bunch of
normal gameplans using my powerful commander. So,
what if instead I went a different direction—what
if I played a pile of scrappy little dudes,
and then dragged the rest of the table down
to their level? This is where discard comes
in—discard doesn’t necessarily say yes
or no—rather, it strips away resources,
forcing my opponents to pick and
choose what they want to keep in hand,
and disproportionately hindering decks doing
more synergistic or complicated things. When
I first conceptualized this deck as a $25
budget deck four years ago, I went with a
bit of an oddball commander choice—Malfegor.
What’s he doing here? Well, the logic is that
with a 99 that is focused on flexible 2-3
drop creatures and 3-4 cost discard spells,
there wasn’t really a need to fit a commander
into my curve, so a higher-cost utility option
works just fine. As for the specific appeals of
Malfegor, well, I’ll get back to that in a bit.
When I went to finally update the 2020 version
of this deck this summer, I started with a full
20 discard spells—the goal is to get the table
hellbent, and you need a lot of discard spells
to do that consistently. Two spells ends up
being a good number to shoot for, and a count
of 20 allows me to draw that within the first 5
draws of the game approximately 75% of the time,
which is good enough for my purposes. This
gave a good starting point for the deck,
but simultaneously posed a problem—20
slots is a lot to spend on a category
of card that broadly doesn’t directly impact
the board. This brings me to a key feature of
the deck—“compactness”. Compactness is a
feature that I find important in general,
and on a basic level it means that decks should
use their slots as efficiently as possible so
as not to overcommit resources to accomplish
tasks. In this case, the deck manages to pack
decent quantities each of cards I’d consider draw
spells and cards I’d consider removal spells in
addition to the discard. The compactness can
be seen when I sort my categories by card type
on Archidekt—11 of the deck’s 14 draw spells are
creatures, as are 9 of its 20 discard spells and
5 of its 14 removal spells. This is critical
because it allows the deck to put on pressure
and keep a high creature count for purposes of
cards that care about that, while still spending
a full 20 slots on cards that force opponents to
discard and 14 slots each for removal and draw.
My Radha deck does something similar—I
cache in around 20 slots up front for ramp,
and then the deck is as dense as possible
with card utility from there. Specifically,
these decks both place a high priority on draw
and removal, running as many cards as possible
that give one of these things while also
serving a different purpose such as being
a beater or an acceleration spell or a land.
This is not done at no cost—there are a lot
of cards that are quite decent generally in
EDH that don’t fit well into this outline.
Protection spells aren’t very compact because
they need something to protect to gain value,
anthem-style cards aren’t very compact because
they require a board of creatures to gain value,
escalation cards that amplify the power of certain
effects aren’t very compact because they require
something to amplify to gain value, and mana
acceleration that is efficient but temporary
isn’t very compact because it requires a specific
followup plan to gain value. None of this is to
say that these cards are bad—some of these
are really fantastic alongside other cards,
but that’s the issue—they’re not reliably helpful
on their own, and the more of them you put in a
deck the more fragile it will be. Each of these
decks I just mentioned mostly avoid these cards,
making an exception for a small quantity of
lifegain because staying alive over the course
of a long game can be a key challenge
for a deck that is grindy and compact.
With the idea of compactness in mind, let’s take
a look at potentially the greatest enabler of
this concept in EDH, the 8th card in hand, so
to speak—the commander. Malfegor is a 6 cost
6/6 flier who discards my hand and forces each
opponent to sacrifice a creature for each card
discarded. This is an odd choice of commander on
the surface—when we look at popular commanders for
discard decks, almost all are either enabler
for making opponents discard or payoff for
making opponents discard. Like c’mon, you’re
playing the commander format—the card that’s
always available to you should relate to
what you’re doing with your deck, right?
However, Malfegor has proved to be an excellent
commander choice for a few different reasons.
For one, Malfegor fills a specific strategic
niche here—one of the main disadvantages of
running a pile of grindy creatures with discard
effects and draw effects attached is that these
creatures don’t generally attack well into
chunky midrange boards. Malfegor serves as
a solution to this issue, providing a way to
blast away blockers and allow me to keep the
pressure on. Malfegor’s effect also pairs
fantastically with discard effects—normally
opponents might avoid overcommitting
to the board if they don’t have tokens
to soak up some of the sacrifice triggers.
However, with a stream of discard spells,
opponents are pressured into making a terrible
choice—either keep that awesome creature in hand
and risk discarding it, or play that creature and
risk losing it to Malfegor. In this way Malfegor
is an example of what I’ll call a “Counterweight
Commander”—he subverts the weaknesses of a discard
deck full of grindy creatures, thereby making
the deck better-rounded. Instead of doing the
same thing as the deck, he does basically the
opposite, and the resulting tension created by
this allows for almost a call and response-esque
play pattern—my board and discard spells prompt
certain play patterns from opponents, and Malfegor
exists as to be my followup to those patterns.
With a commander that discards my hand on
ETB, this deck naturally ended up needing
to focus on another factor that’s related
to compactness—Resilience. What that means
is that a deck can recover from setbacks
readily—challenges thrown its way can be
shrugged off with relative ease. This is a good
deck attribute to go for in general—it creates
more positive play experiences for everybody
at the table when decks can recover easily from
setbacks, and most of my decks feature this as a
critical feature in some way or other. However,
this deck takes it to a whole different level,
because it doesn’t wait for its opponents to set
it back—oh no, this deck takes a baseball bat to
its own kneecaps. Of the deck’s 20 discard spells,
more than a third affect me as well, and
as I’ve mentioned, the deck’s commander
literally makes you discard your hand. Nobody at
the table is allowed to keep cards in their hand,
not even me—step one of this deck is that
we’re all getting dragged down into the
mud for some rough and dirty Magic: the Gathering
gameplay. The natural followup is that this deck
is specifically engineered to be unusually good
at playing under exactly those circumstances.
I mentioned the deck’s draw being mostly creature
based, and the other important fact about the draw
suite here is that most of the draw spells are
what I’d refer to as discrete engines. By discrete
I mean that these cards largely don’t rely on
other cards to generate card advantage, and by
engine I mean that these cards give card advantage
over time. One of these requires a player to be
hellbent to be online, which is helped by playing
discard spells or Malfegor, and four others
require dealing combat damage to players, which
can be assisted by removing opposing creatures,
but the rest kinda just hang around and provide a
stream of cards with minimal extra input required.
This makes these a wonderfully flexible type of
card—they’re great as topdeck, they’re great as a
last card kept in hand while playing a big discard
spell like Delirium Skeins, and most are also
great to land on curve as well. The other thing
that makes this deck resilient is its graveyard
package—there are five different cards that
can recur things from the graveyard, and there
are also five cards that can be cast from the
graveyard, or that can otherwise get value from
being in the graveyard in some capacity. There are
an additional five cards with madness and another
two that provide benefits as a result of the deck
discarding cards, and all of these components
combine to allow the deck to somewhat mitigate
the downsides of discarding large quantities of
cards. Not fully mitigate, mind you—the deck still
gets to a hellbent state and feels it, but it at
least has some tools to allow it to play through
that hellbent state better than a lot of decks.
In addition, an unexpected feature of the deck has
been that discarding one’s hand isn’t entirely a
bad thing. See, Malfegor’s one-with-nothing ETB
also has a social benefit. The deck’s early turns
are often spent stripping away opposing hands, and
this is a frustrating experience for my opponents,
an experience that is only amplified when Malfegor
comes down to demolish some creatures as well.
Looking at the person who cleared out your
hand and killed your creatures would be pretty
upsetting if they still had a full grip of cards,
and they’d be a magnet for attacks and removal.
However, if they’re also hellbent and have a
board entirely consisting of a 6/6 flier and
some utility 3/3s, well—things aren’t as clear.
I’ve frequently gotten a visceral sense of mixed
feelings from opponents while playing this deck—my
opponents *wish* I was the unambiguous threat
so they could have a good excuse to attack
me, but I’m often barely ahead at all, and
sometimes it’s entirely unclear to my opponents
who is ahead. The threat profile of a low-slung,
grindy deck is just not one that most EDH players
are used to needing to consider—what do you do
with a player who isn’t an imminent threat to
your life total, isn’t setting up for a combo,
and isn’t scaling up to an overwhelming late
game? The deck is perfectly capable of winning
games through a mixture of attrition and beatdown,
but it manages to fly under the radar more than
you’d expect even after doing a bunch of nasty
stuff to its opponents. In this way, Malfegor
is critical to the deck for vibes reasons—he is
the key to turning games from an epic wizard duel
into a knife fight being fought in four inch
deep mud, for myself and my opponents alike.
Speaking of vibes, let’s talk about one of the
oddest conclusions of the deckbuilding process.
One of the exciting things about upgrading
this deck over the summer was that I could
finally play with Waste Not, since the previous
version of the deck was an ultra-budget list and
since there was now an Enchanting Tales reprint
that was both cheap and super cool looking. I’m
playing a discard deck, so a card that gives
me various assorted benefits when opponents
discard is a perfect fit, right? However,
one of the first games I played with the
deck was an utterly disgusting game for the
card—turn 2 Waste not, turn 3 Arterial Flow,
and continuing onward and upward from there. It
felt great from a power level perspective—the deck
was keeping a pretty full grip and accelerating
forward in its gameplan even as the rest of the
table was struggling to keep up under the weight
of its discard, but something also felt very wrong
about it. After a bit of reflection it became
clear what the problem was—the whole point of the
deck was to play scrappy, dragging the rest of the
table down into a fight in the mud and then being
really good at winning mud fights. A big piece
of what made this deck work on a vibes level was
that the deck had no central engine like Waste
Not—it had a bunch of little individual ones,
but none of them were enough to be a load-bearing
pillar for the deck’s gameplan. The fact that
advantage is fought for tooth-and-nail with
a bunch of disconnected little engines is
a defining feature of the deck, and it’s
what makes the deck so grindy and flexible.
This approach contrasts that of many EDH decks.
It’s quite common to feature a central engine in
the command zone—the commander is the center of a
synergy pillar, and it has a number of other cards
that generate some form of value when played
alongside it. When I go to the top commanders,
around half of them follow this mold—Atraxa
generates value with counters cards, Ur-Dragon
with dragons, Yuriko with ninjas, Miirym also with
dragons, Isshin with attack ability creatures,
Jodah with legendaries—you get it. In the best
cases, an engine commander is one that plays
to the strengths of a card type, serving as an
anchor for that type that hopefully passes the
vibe check. However, not all engines pass that
vibe check. One example of an engine I have mixed
feelings about is Anje Falkenrath, because she
doesn’t really play to the strengths of madness.
She can enable them, but the design of the card
is such that just chaining through a whole bunch
of madness cards while paying for few, if any,
madness costs and then doing graveyard shenanigans
or pulling off a combo is usually better than
focusing more heavily on casting cards via
madness. You could replace the word madness with
a do-nothing mechanic called Scrungus on both Anje
and the now-Scrungus cards, and the playstyle
of most Anje decks wouldn’t change that much.
All of this brings me to one of my
least favorite engine commanders,
and one that is very similar to Waste Not—Tergrid,
God of Fright. Tergrid is, structurally speaking,
a pretty conventional engine commander—maybe a
little feast or famine, but in a similar realm
to something like Jodah or Miirym. So it exists
in a normal-ish plane of existence for an engine
commander, but counterintuitively this is exactly
why the card is one of the most hated commanders
out there. See, Tergrid is an engine that works
with discard and sacrifice effects, stealing and
putting into play all cards that get discarded or
sacrificed by opponents. Why is this a problem?
Well fundamentally, it’s due to the nature of
these tools. Discard and sacrifice both have
valid places in commander, but they’re tools that
should be used with a specific purpose in mind.
Casual commander is naturally going to involve
a negotiation between what is fun for other
people and what makes for interesting games—the
comfort of other players at the table will be
weighed against other factors, at least in some
form. The issue with using sacrifice and discard
effects as engine fodder, then, is that these
unpleasant tools become frivolous and impassive,
equivalent to just another filler dragon in a
dragon deck. Instead of deploying these tools
in a way that is targeted and strategic, the
Tergrid player creates a bland engine powered
entirely by the suffering of their opponents,
and is encouraged to play as many edicts and
discard spells as possible rather than a number
chosen to fulfill a certain strategic role.
In contrast to this, my Malfegor deck’s hate
tools are run very intentionally with specific
goals in mind. The deck runs a bunch of discard
spells because it needs to kneecap opponents in
order to not fall behind in value, and it
runs Malfegor in the command zone because
it needs a tool to break through intimidating
boards and let its small creatures connect for
damage. The benefits of opponents discarding and
opponents losing creatures are mostly indirect,
with the deck seeing benefits to its overall
strategy from these things rather than having
a bunch of cards that specifically do things when
opponents lose cards and permanents. In addition,
the fact that the deck also plays low to the
ground means that opponents don’t feel like
they’re being smushed into submission
while the discard player gets to do
some stupid explosive bullshit. No, I
don’t get to play any sort of explosive
midrange Magic either—that’s just not
the sort of commander game we’re playing.
Now, does this mean my Malfegor deck isn’t going
to make opponents sad? Absolutely not! Discard
effects, and especially discard engines like
Bottomless pit, are a form of stax effect and
they will hinder my opponents’ ability to play
the game. Certainly, my goal with this deck is to
change the shape and scale of the game rather than
preventing my opponents from playing it—I want us
all to play a scrappy, topdecking cage fight of
a Magic game rather than some stupid thing where
everybody is constantly stacking resources and
racing synergy engines. And the deck does obtain
this vision some amount of the time, but the
biggest weakness of the deck in power and fun
terms alike is that certain opponents will be much
less harmed by my discard spells than others. See,
the power of non-random discard is inversely
proportional to the number of cards in somebody’s
hand up until the point at which they’ve been
hellbent in a game—if I make a player discard
a card when they have five cards in hand, the
quality of that card will be much lower than
if I forced them to discard a card at two cards in
hand. The result of this is that if somebody lands
an early value engine and is able to avoid
dipping below three or four cards in hand,
they’re going to have a much, much better time
than somebody who was forced to go down to one
card in hand or fully hellbent, even if the
two players discarded equal numbers of cards.
In addition, decks with graveyard synergies
are going to be much better able to cope than
decks without. The worst case scenario is that
I basically act as a kingmaker, all but handing
the win to the person with the person who is
best-equipped to handle discard. It’s rare
that things are this dramatic, but it has happened
before and it feels pretty terrible when it does.
Is this a solvable problem? Kind of. The
graveyard thing is—I’ve gradually pumped
the number of graveyard hate cards up to
5, and these have actually been shockingly
smooth additions. Modern Horizons III contained a
couple of lovely flexible options, and Immersturm
Predator is another grave-hate engine that has
great extra utility as a boardwipe-resistant
flying beater. The issue of draw engines is
definitely a trickier one, though. The amount of
enchantment hate available in Rakdos is currently
pretty unimpressive, and there are also forms of
draw that are harder to slow down with removal.
That leaves the option of single-target discard,
for when one opponent still has a decent grip but
the others are puttering around with one or fewer
in hand. Hymn to Tourach and Mind Twist are about
as good as it gets for single target discard,
but these are neither efficient in the early
game nor all that great as a topdeck later. The
other option is Specters, creatures that force an
opponent to discard when they connect for damage,
but these are also largely not powerful enough to
make the cut. Hypnotic Specter is somehow both the
oldest and the best one and it’s acceptable
enough to be an evergreen maybe-board card,
but the rest are pretty much all 4 drops
that I wish were 3 drops or 3 drops that
I wish were sauced up a bit with some extra
stats and keywords. For the moment, I’ll be
keeping an eye on the problem and potentially
experimenting with some of the single-target
discard options that do exist, and for the future
I’ll just hope that the card gods at Wizards of
the Coast bless me with a new specter that is
more prepared for the demands of 2024 Magic.
Despite its challenges, this
deck has been a success overall,
both in terms of creating a deck on the right
power level for the games I want to play
and in terms of chasing the vibe I was looking
to chase. I’ve known for years that the Malfegor
deck was my favorite of the decks from the $25
pool, with its grindy-to-the-max gameplay leading
to some really interesting games, and I’m glad
to have maintained that with the upgrade. Above
all else it’s an extremely fun deck—there
is a calculated recklessness to every play,
and it’s so fun to be able to play fast and
loose with both life total and cards in hand.
I had a game recently where I played Malfegor
discarding my 6 card hand, then activated
Spymaster’s Vault to cycle through some more
cards and put four +1/+1 counters on Malfegor,
then swung 15 at an opponent since I now had an
Anger in my graveyard from all that discarding,
and during all of this I was on 5 life with two
Dark Confidant effects on board threatening to
end me on each of my upkeeps. I survived
more than two full turn cycles after this,
by the way—lots of lands happened to be on top.
That sort of play is, to me, the defining feature
of the deck—being able to throw all caution
to the wind, to commit to plays as hard as is
physically possible, and to find creative ways to
rebuild and come up with resources after it looks
like I should be all out of gas. It’s a playstyle
that is antithetical to my control player roots,
and even a bit antithetical to commander as most
people currently know it, but that’s the appeal.
Finding new and fresh ways to play will always
be a big goal for me in EDH, as will be creating
decks that evoke a highly specific feeling.
And, this deck is certainly one version of that.
That’s the end of the video but I have a very
special announcement! I recently hit 50 thousand
subscribers, which is super cool, and to celebrate
I’m going to be running a deckbuilding challenge
through my Discord server. Malfegor has around
300 decks on EDHRec as of publishing this video,
which is quite a small count for how cool the card
is, and it occurred to me that there are a lot of
other similarly underappreciated commanders
out there that could use a bit more love. So,
for this challenge I picked out five different
monocolored commanders I like that have less
than 200 decks on EDHRec. Those commanders are
Eomer Marshal of Rohan, Yomiji Who Bars the Way,
Egon God of Death, Shizuko Caller of Autumn, and
Senator Peacock. To participate in this challenge,
construct a deck with one of these
five commanders, and then post it in
the submission thread in my Discord server within
one week of this video’s upload. So to be clear,
that deadline will be Tuesday 30th at 9am PST.
Judging criteria will be creativity, cohesiveness,
and likelihood to create dynamic gameplay. Any
power level, any budget. My next video will
feature a deck that me and my team determine best
fits this prompt for each of the five commanders,
so you can keep an eye out for that regardless
of if you participate. With that said,
thanks for watching, and if you want to support me
in doing what I do, a link to my Patreon is down
in the description. If you want more Snail and
don’t want to give me money, I was on an episode
of the Magic Mirror podcast this week, and me and
my cohosts ranked each other’s most played decks.
It was a lot of fun, and quite interesting to
see how my main 6 decks stacked up in other
people’s eyes. A link to that is also down in
the description. Alright, that’s all, bye now.